[Music]
hi and welcome to trading spouses the
show where we take to married couples
and you guessed it make them trade
spouses for a whole month watch the
sparks fly today because for the first
time on our show we're going interracial
that is gonna wait for a little while
alright I'm going to live with a white
family
y'all be good family TV show
say hi to America it might try to touch
your mother punch him in his lips son
dad's going away for a few weeks so I
want you to be good okay squirt a little
Tmart would you like to call me daddy is
it okay if I call you mr. Dees mr. deeds
I don't understand
you must be Leonard that's right can I
call you daddy
hell no oh your mom calls my daddy take
my bear go to my room
and if I find out you been going through
my don't want beaching yeas oh yeah I'm
glad you asked little buddy
this here is cauliflower this is corned
beef hash
and these are parsnips what does a
parsnip usually do the dishes after
dinner well just so you know his ass
will be back April 13th
don't eat anger laptop you do your
homework
well go on stay as a wash a and then
we'll watch Martin Lawrence you may
light your cigarette for you too we
check your tone girl PS our voices so
cliche
[Applause]
racial profiling is Renee Zellweger
What's Wrong sweetie team arts been
back-talking me and I need you to take
care of it for me
see Mart
I'll be right back you're in big trouble
mister
what you gonna hit me or something
you're going on timeout for 15 minutes
okay starting now team art timeout
[Applause]
the hell are you missing her to new 50
cent I'm from the streets man juju GU
[Applause]
huh hey y'all my top home sweet home the
hood all right little fella
say hello to people for me and tell me
you see him the little Washington's glad
he made it out go boom
goodbye and if you need money sell rocks
I heard that's what it do around here
[Music]
the hell damn bitch was just a light
signal
night-night
do you want to have sex with me tired
yes I would like that very much
do you mind if I turn off this hard B
music I kind of want to hear you
breathing okay okay do you want to take
off your pajama bottoms actually I feel
more comfortable if I just pull my penis
home I'm sorry baby I don't go south of
the border is just one thing that Lenin
Washington don't do but Leonard it's
okay I'm waxed dang not unheard of
trimming the hedges but you don't Scotia
earth
I smell your lightsaber lightsaber
[Music]
Leonard and I hardly even talk anymore
the other night he came home at 3 in the
morning I had no idea where he was he
uses profanity around Jeffrey I just
don't feel like we're sharing I I don't
feel like there's any reciprocity there
how did you feel about all this Leonard
bitch I'll never forgive you for this
don't leave in the car warm it up this
is good you can let out whatever you
feel in here Leonard all right I'm gonna
tell you right now ain't crazy I don't
need no psychiatrist and if you ever
tell anybody I've been in here it's just
between us
wouldn't confidentially I am crazy and
out you know wild and crazy fun let's
see what our interracial families have
learned I learned a lot from chiron
and I learned a lot from little T Martin
quite frankly I'll miss them both very
much
and for the first time in my life I
tasted brown sugar and not in my oatmeal
taught me that no matter where you come
from you know saying oh what color your
skin is we all pretty much do the same
things in the life raise our kids make
nerve from town of time and wash
speaking of which I learned there why
people don't use wash clothes did you
know that I'm serious they had one bar
soap in the house every time I use it
someone else's pubic hair was in it I
get the call my guys gonna put the raw
bar soap and your button all this we're
gonna need to wash my face on my feet
Todd Leonard are very different although
Lynn is the love of my life in a
different world I could see myself with
Todd
although the penis through the whole
thing was kind of weird and I am missing
some of my drawers
oh my gosh Oh
titty residue
[Music]
[Applause]